hi everyone and thank you for joining my
talk today I'm going to be talking about
uh customizing and evaluating llms so
I'm planning on saying this but uh as
you probably have heard Google has
launched uh Gemini their long awaited
model is supposed to beat uh gp4 and I
noticed an interesting thing today uh
which is that when they publish the
results the metrics that they used to
evaluate their model were pretty
different from the original metrics that
open AI used to evaluate gp4 which which
means that we're kind of comparing uh
apples to oranges and so I thought it
was funny that today I'm speaking about
this topic uh when it seems like this is
a prevalent problem even in like the
most advanced Labs So today we're going
to be talking about customizing and
evaluating llms and hopefully this is
useful to not only uh Google and open AI
but everyone here um so starting with a
short story just to make this more
realistic you get into your office on a
Monday and you see an email from your
boss he spoke with the CEO of the
company who promised the board of
directors that the company will live up
to the promises in its pitch deck to be
AI driven with everyone talking about
this in the news I'm sure you or genius
ml engineer can figure it out everyone
is doing it so why can't we so you sit
down to think about what you should do
next everyone is talking about chat for
this chat for that so I guess we should
chat with our
product but how can you get some llm
that was trained on God knows what to
answer questions about your product how
can it answer correctly know its
limitations and how can you make sure
it's performing well uh well enough
before you put it in front of your users
let's go ahead and find out so James
already presented me I won't repeat uh
everything that he said but my
background is a combo of physics machine
learning uh and computer science and I'm
really passionate about building tools
that help machine learning teams work
together I'm also a strong believer in
open source and the role it has in the
world of AEL those two things let me to
found uh the company that I I'm working
at uh which is called dags Hub and we're
basically building a platform for ML and
AI teams and I also do the mlops podcast
uh and hopefully this at least to a
certain extent answers your question of
why you should listen to me uh and
before I move on I'll just say um I I
can see that there are messages in the
chat and stuff like that I'll answer all
the questions in the end but feel free
to write them as you have them in mind
and I'll go over them from top to
bottom so what are we going to cover
today if you're not living in a cave you
probably know that llms have been making
a lot of Buzz and this Buzz doesn't seem
to be dying down and as llms become
ubiquitous everyone is scrambling to
apply them in their company and inside
their products and this is specifically
seems that it specifically seems that
due to the fact that one of the best
things about chat GPT uh the llm that
slingshotted all others into the general
uh public sphere was its chat ux
everyone is in the mental model of chat
for my product but it doesn't have to be
the case two major challenges have
Arisen uh or more precisely reappeared
in this context yet again the first is
customizing and the second is evaluating
your models and what I'd like to do
today is cover the basics and provide
some ideas on how you might go ahead and
customize your llm uh to your needs
followed by how to evaluate them and
make sure that they are performing well
and within the constraints that you uh
need them
to so a quick uh llm recap with a few
thoughts um when we say llms are large
language models we're not just talking
about fancy chat Bots there are
sophisticated systems that understand
and generate humanlike text and the
essence of llms lies in their capacity
to not only parse language but to
understand its nuances and generate
contextually relevant humanlike
responses they're not just algorithms
that simulate conversations and they're
not even just participants in a
conversation what I'd like to argue
today is that thinking about them in
this way is sort of the banal or boring
approach the boring use Cas is chatting
with your application but if you think
about llms as automated reasoning
engines you can come up with infinitely
diverse applications it's not just about
chatting with a human it's about that
can do things and though of course this
isn't a fully solve problem just yet
with agents and everything I've already
seen and heard of real world
applications that take advantage of this
mental model so to give an example that
I found eye opening in a fraud detection
use case and this is a real use case
that's been applied in production a team
decided to use an llm to play the role
of a gullible person that is just asking
to be defrauded when scammers would
reach out the bot would interact with
them and in the process of being scammed
would get some some identification
detail from the scammer this was then
sent back to a database and used to
check against for future transactions
effectively blocking those accounts from
the relevant uh platform so this is
probably not what most common uh lolm
applications look like today but I think
as time goes by they'll look more and
more like these things so why do we want
to customize llms llms were trained on
the entire internet uh but sometimes
they need to work for data they weren't
trained on whether it's a specific
domain knowledge or more importantly
organizational knowledge uh databases so
take for example a legal firm that is
using an llm for document review a
general model might grasp the legal
jargon the basic one but a fine-tune
model with specific legal data sets can
understand the nuances of case law
statutory language and of course the
specific cases that this firm is working
on leading to improved accuracy and
utility similarly in healthcare a
customized llm trained in medical
literature and patient data can interact
with clinicians more effectively
understanding complex medical
terminology that a generic model might
misinterpret so in the context of a
medical uh llm customization is not just
beneficial it's imperative by tailoring
uh an llm we gain control over Its
Behavior ensuring that it operates
within the strict boundaries of medical
accuracy
it's not it must not only understand
complex medical terms but also provide
valid references and avoid any
potentially harmful uh
misinformation in a domain where the
stakes are high and the margin for error
is low the Precision of a customized LM
can make all the difference in patient
outcomes and Trust in AI assisted
healthare last but not least proprietary
data is arguably the new modes the more
you have it the better your product will
be and the better your ability to
collect more data and improve your model
even more note that since incumbents
typically have more users in data this
might help them maintain control or
tighten control over a market but can
also be used by smaller startups if the
incumbent isn't as data literate as you
are Beyond enhancing user experience and
ensuring accuracy customizing llm
applications also serves as a strategic
move in a competitive market and a
tailored llm can differentiate your
product by providing a unique experience
or specialized knowledge that generic
generic models can't offer so assuming
you agree with me so far um that we
probably want to customize LMS let's go
ahead and start but unfortunately
customizing LMS is still pretty hard
finding enough
highquality domain specific data for
training or fine-tuning an llm can be a
pretty significant obstacle and this
data might must be representative uh
diverse and free of biases to be
effective incorporating specialized
knowledge into an llm often requires
expertise not only in machine learning
but also in the relevant domain whether
it's legal medical Financial or some
other field that means that the
technical people who are doing this
customization uh need to communicate and
work well with the domain experts who
are usually less
Technical and we should overlook the
ethical Dimension LL can perpetuate and
amplify biases that are present in their
training data and ensuring that the
models are fair and unbiased is a
complicated challenge in general and uh
uh can require sort of careful data
curation and testing and obviously it's
even more challenging when you get to
LMS due to the volatility um and
complexity of those models and last but
not least customizing llms especially
through methods like fine-tuning or
retraining can require a lot of comput
ational power which could be costly and
time consuming and even once you
customize the first version they're
going to need ongoing updates and
maintenance to stay current with the
latest knowledge and data which can be a
resource intensive
process so let's dive into the meat of
it how can we approach customizing our
llms when it comes to customizing them
there's a spectrum of strategies that is
at our disposal and here's how I
personally rank the different ways to
customize an llm by the level of
difficulty and the effort required I'm
going to go over them in a moment and
provide tips but at a bird's eyee view
we have the easy modification Zone which
I uh put into that category prompt
engineering and custom logic they're
like a quick toolkit for instant
customization which uh require no
training but a sort of creative approach
to guiding the model if you're not sure
what to do start experimenting with them
these are things that you can sort of
hack together and they might even be
within reach for non-technical folks uh
within your team in the middle we have
the hard mode uh which could be relevant
in cases where you have more resources
to apply and the the easy mode is not
good enough for you they'll usually
require a dedicated team member or an
entire team and a lot of technical
knowhow so this is also not a linear
scale even though it might look this way
and the distance between tier three and
for can be huge finally in the danger
zone I really wasn't even sure if I
should include this here since these are
sort of uh developments you could
consider research or building a model um
in and of itself that I think that there
are very few organizations that can pull
these off they're resource intensive uh
uh processes and uh you're basically
creating a new model from scratch
they're not typically recommended unless
you're T tackling some exceptionally
challenging problem that existing models
can solve or you're operating at the
Forefront of AI research like at openi
Google or whatever and I'm probably not
going to go into them uh anymore during
this talk unless there are specific
questions hopefully I'll be able to
answer so the first two tiers are prompt
engineering and custom logic so prompt
engineering or few shot learning by way
of prompt engineering are good for
providing context and nudging the model
towards the desired output It suffers
from the problem that prompt engineering
still today is an Arcane technique you
need to know the magic spells and
there's a lot of non-trivial quirks to
how to do it well but we've seen
personally a dags when we've applied
this in a smart way that it gets to
really awesome results without requiring
uh to bring in data scientists or ml
Engineers custom logic means defining
some external logic and by external I
mean external to the model that
processes the llms inputs and outputs
and this is suitable when you want to
enhance functionality without changing
the model itself this can in include
retrieval mechanisms for getting
external context for your LL we'll talk
about that in a moment one major benefit
of these methods is that in principle
they don't require data to work more or
less right perhaps uh you need a few
examples or something like that so the
overhead is basically none now also
implementing custom logic around the the
model is possibly simultaneously most
popular and most overlooked
customization it's the most popular
because of rag but overlooked because it
doesn't have to be just rag why mess
with the model if you can solve your
needs by working around it you can set
up again this is all examples that I've
heard uh uh I've seen or heard applied
in the market or we've applied them
theel ourselves so you can set up rules
to filter re responses use more
classical controllable explainable mod
models to verify the input and the
output um and modify the models context
depending on their results or use apis
to get reliable context which reminds me
that we finally need to talk about rag
for a few moments so rag or retrieval
augmented Generation Um this sort of
falls under the custom logic category
since we're not directly affecting the
model but creating an efficient context
retrieval mechanism for it this is also
probably the most popular way to
customize llms again maybe aside from
prompt engineering uh and here the model
dynamically pulls an information from
external databases to inform its
responses and this is usually uh based
on some Vector similarity search a topic
for a different talk I'm sure there are
a lot of talks uh this year about this
um and the main advantage of of rag is
that updating the model context is much
simpler you simply update the documents
it retrieves from uh compared to
updating the model itself now note that
this introduces another dependency which
needs to be managed can slow the
application down and is another point of
failure that you that might be hard to
debug if your llm isn't providing the
desired uh responses but I'll also say
that now when everyone is talking about
rag I think most people think about
Vector databases and notice that the
name doesn't really mention that and it
doesn't have to be uh based on Vector
search you might use the model to define
a different query and use that to supply
context or you use information that you
know about the customer or the user to
provide that context that would still
fall under this category and I think
that's going to be as common if not more
common than the vector similarity search
which requires again a lot more Arcane
understanding of how these things work
to make it work
properly so in the second tier in hard
mode we have PFT and Laura or parameter
efficient fine-tuning Plus low rank
adaptation and these are methods for eff
efficient domain adaptation this
shouldn't suffer as much as for uh from
catastrophic catastrophic forgetting um
and it's useful when you need more than
a nudge from prompt engineering but want
to avoid the full cost of retraining I
really recommend you read the papers
behind this since I believe this is
going to become more and more of an
important tool in your customization uh
toolbox as time goes by and by the way
some of you might have heard of Laura
only in the context of diffusion models
but it works equally well for llms that
do tax generation fine-tuning and model
retraining involve uh comprehensive
fine-tuning and retraining of the model
on new data it's a deeper level of
customization for when your use case
Demands a model that the pre-trained
version simply can provide however the
technical requirements for this are very
high and I would argue that the two
steps that have the large Gap here are
between PFT and and Laura and fine
tuning and model ret trining again if I
don't include the heart Zone um the I
think most industry teams that are
pursuing this method uh um have low
chances of success so I wouldn't go here
unless you've exhausted all the previous
methods and are certain that you won't
achieve your needs from them as a side
note just to give you some like ballpark
figures from this when open AI uh
launched the the um the updated apis and
and did their recent Dev day they open a
registration form to get gbd4 trained on
your data um which could you could argue
is similar to four plus five and they
estimated the cost of this at two to3
million so this gives you some estimate
for whether or not your organization can
afford doing something like this and as
we Ascend rhf or reinforcement learning
from Human feedback is a way to imbu
models with uh Nuance understanding
through interactive feedback from humans
um this approach is most beneficial when
the model's output must be highly
aligned with complex human judgment and
to be honest when I was ranking these
things I wasn't sure if I should put
four before five or the other way around
so I think these are hard things to set
up and if you look to for example Andre
kpa's uh talk which I'm linking to in
the end um about gpts he ranks rhf
higher and that's why I decided to go
with this ranking so just to double down
on Laura I think that Laura and PFT are
really really important methods that are
often overlooked for domain adaptation I
recommend that checking them out and if
the previous methods have not gotten you
where you need and or if you need a more
flexible solution so taking a model that
you know works and moving it into a
domain that is uh I don't know different
like fundamentally different from from
the origin domain that the model was
trained on you should use those uh uh
these methods in that case um and this
has also the advantage of being
reasonable to do for each customer so
you're trying to build something where
you say I need to redo it or or do a
domain adaptation per customer um Laura
might be the way to go
here so of course it doesn't have to be
just one or another uh approach you can
use multiple things uh together so if
you're using one two and three they can
work great uh with each other and
specifically rag works with every other
customization technique uh that I've
seen and now that we have our customized
model right or the approaches to
customize our model we need to evaluate
it to make sure it's behaving nicely but
of course evaluating llms presents its
own set of complex challenges first we
need metrics that truly capture the
model's performance and all NE Neary
Dimensions not just the accuracy but
also fluency coherence relevance
consistency and user satisfaction and
comparative metrics like the L rating
and I think that the Google Gemini issue
uh that we've seen today is sort of an
example of that so you want to make sure
that you're comparing Apples to Apples
if it's a publicity issue then maybe it
doesn't matter as much but when you're
trying to prove to yourself that your
model is actually good enough to go to
production you want to make sure that
you're evaluating it for real with
something that that actually conveys the
the value or the change compared to
previous
versions we also need to make sure that
our evaluation data is representative
free from biases covers relevant edge
cases and the things we actually care
about this might be more than one data
set um and we want to make sure that we
um understand how and why our model uh
or sorry understanding how and why our
model made the decisions it did is
always difficult uh but with llms it's
nearly impossible and this becomes a
critical point in high-stake domains
like medical and legal applications
where user trust in compliance with
regulations are Paramount
considerations and last but not least
these are sort of some of the main
challenges in llm evaluation and many
people smarter than I have claimed that
this is currently the biggest Gap in the
llm world and I tend to agree one
additional Point here is that evaluation
tends to be case-by case specific so
it's really hard to just copy paste
things that other people have done and a
lot of judgment and customization is
needed here uh too so let's go over a
few ideas that um I think could be
useful when you're building your
evaluation uh capabilities for the llms
that you're
customizing our evaluation toolkit needs
to include mainly two types of uh
evaluation tests the first is automated
and the second is arguably
semi-automated um you could call this uh
reference and preference-based methods
which I like I like this uh terminology
so reference-based methods are things
like Rouge which is a metric that's
predefined you can basically calculate
it for your model and create sort of a
quantitative Benchmark and
preference-based methods leverage human
choice for comparative evaluation so for
example you take two options that were
generated as a response to the same
prompt by two different models or two
different model versions and asking
people to decide which one is the better
option and then we can use that for
evaluation for example to calculate the
Lo rating I actually have a project um
on dags Hub called DPT that has an
evaluation example for doing exactly
that so that could be one way to imbue
human judgment into the evaluation
process the second thing is you need to
build specialized data sets think of
them kind of like data unit tests
focused on crucial areas like like
toxicity biases and edge cases so these
are the yard sticks that we're going to
use to ensure that our models behave
responsibly and we can take a sort of P
fail approach to some of these even uh
deciding that if a model fails for
example a toxicity test they cannot be
deployed to production um and this is
really um like really it's relatively
straightforward and I think it's really
powerful to incorporate these and I
haven't seen this done enough um and and
I think we're going to see again more
and more of this happening within the
industry the other thing that you can do
is you can utilize a stronger llm like
gbd4 for meta evaluation so in that case
we're posing complicated questions about
for example consistency with the source
material or the potential for bias in
the outputs pushing the boundaries of
traditional evaluation methods so this
does does require defining the
evaluation properly but examples I've
seen that could prove useful are asking
the stronger llm is this generation
consistent with the source material or
does this result contain information
that might be interpreted as toxic or
biased uh and this works surprisingly
well I'll also share a tool in the end
that helps you do
this the other thing that you can do is
output validation and collecting
feedback from production you can release
your product to early users who can
validate the outputs and give feedback
and that can be a great way to get more
data on where to improve the your model
where missing guard rails might be and
even data can be used uh to improve it
or create a data set of failure modes
that need to be tested against note that
user feedback is sparse but you can do
smart things like uh measure when a user
asks the model to answer a second time
uh or measure other product interactions
that you anticipate are related uh to
your LM performance and use that as well
now obviously this is very Case by case
but this could be really valuable
finally despite all these things there's
no replacement for also eyeballing your
model outputs many times metrics might
not have the full picture so manual
examination is recommended but don't
only do that um so Tulie I'm going to go
over this quickly and then uh try to
answer a few questions um so a few tools
that I think could be useful for the
process of customizing and evaluating
llms mlflow is a great tool for
evaluating and customizing llms it
offers great uh features for prompt
engineering experiment tracking which
you can use to track fine-tuning lur or
retraining experiments and it even has
features for tracking evaluations of
LMS uh hugging face has the evaluate and
the PF libraries they're open source
libraries that provide a ton of metrics
out of the box and Scaffolding to help
you run PFT or Laura easily they both
integrate with mlflow and can be used to
easily calculate the reference-based
metrics that we discussed earlier for
the actual llm model testing the
automated
gascard and deep checks are great
Solutions gascard is an open source
library that integrates with mlflow and
provides interactive reports as well as
metrics that utilize llm explainers
standard metrics and more and will help
you get started quickly and deep chicks
is a hosted platform that does that uh
for human eval methods label studio is a
tool that supports comparison and
ranking templates for text which means
it can be used for the various
preference human in the lube Evol
processes and then dsub uh we help you
integrate all of these things and
provide a hosted environment to use both
mlflow and label studio uh so you can
use that to manage and evaluate your llm
projects
easily to wrap up we navigated through
all the complexity of customizing and
evaluating llms understanding the
challenges in the Strategic workflows to
overcome these things and in terms of
tools and re resources I hope I provided
some things that you can use um this is
sort of recommended uh further reading
if you're interested um and I'll just
show this thing because it's nice and go
back to this in case anyone wants to
take screenshots let's take a few
moments to answer um questions um so I
see there's uh one question from Anthony
does doing Laura help with um rag type
applications is there a specific way of
training lauras for those type of
applications so I think that rag is sort
of uh and Laura are kind of like uh
orthogonal you can do both I'd use uh
rag when you're specifically trying to
get the model to answer about asserted
in context um and Laura when you're
trying to get it to sort of change the
way it thinks to a different domain so
if you give it some context and you ask
it questions about that that's one thing
that you could do but when you low the
model it's going to sort of come at the
problem that you're asking with a sort
of a um domain expertise that's closer
to the domain in which which you want to
operate and so I think you should first
do rag because it's simpler but if
that's not enough and the models kind of
has a tendency to maybe misinterpret the
documents that it's getting or something
like that then using the uh Lura
approach um Can can improve the the the
performance now on the Q&A uh side I see
David is asking in the field of
evaluation I would also add how to
assess the right llm for a given use
case do you have any device tips or
tools um for this sorry Al you wanted to
say something no I'm just saying we're
coming up on time here so um been quick
few seconds on that one otherwise we can
move to Discord and wrap it up sure so
just to answer this um there are a lot
of tools that help you create a test
Suite of prompts you want to use and
then create a table emow does this as
well where you run your prompt uh your
prompt across multiple models and then
you can I all the difference and you can
also use this result to calculate some
metrics depending on uh whether or not
you have the preference uh option set up
or you have some reference methods so
that's how I would approach this um but
but that's but you're right like you
might have different llms that are
better for different use cases and you
might even want to deploy multiple llms
for different use cases depending on the
questions that uh you need to answer so
that's I think it what we have time for